bonsoir la france en bleu tout le pays
retient son souffle à 24 heures d'une
finale de rêve france brésil
aujourd'hui c'était le moment ou jamais
de s'offrir le maillot de l'équipe de
france tenus indispensable pour tous
supporters des bleus certains magasins
ont vendu jusqu'à 150 maillot par jour
et toutes les boutiques ou presque sont
en rupture de stock reportage de peggy
le roy et jacques gauthier footix
possédons monnaie les vedettes des
rayons ce n'est pas lui mais le maillot
des bleus sur les champs elysées le
magasin de la coupe a été livrée ce
matin à midi il est en rupture de stock
je parle à dieu en avoir une 220 à 250
et voilà rester chez vingtaine ou une
trentaine
grosse bataille grosse bataille même
combat dans les magasins de sport y
trouver sa taille parmi les derniers
maillots bleus relève de l'exploit
aujourd'hui la tenue de l'équipe de
france s'élève à 400 francs environ
demain elle pourrait devenir un
collector le fournisseur arrête la
fabrication ce soir mais dany maillot
que j'ai eues en grande taille ont été
vendus à vendargues anglais s'étaient
réservés
ceux qui sont là sont pas réservés non
ces petites tailles ccc là dessus vous
avez le plus de stock et là bon je pense
que ce soir je croyais un classé loin
derrière les couleurs brésiliennes au
début du mondial les bleus a finalement
trouvé le chemin des caisses les ventes
ont décollé juste après les quarts de
finale le premier grand succès des
hommes d'aimé jacquet des victoires sur
lesquels ni le fournisseur ni les grands
magasins n'aurait parié pas honnêtement
on n'avait pas prévu cet engouement sur
les produits coupe du monde
on était peut-être un peu dépassé par
les événements mais on ne pensait pas
non plus que la france irait si loin
dimanche soir la vague bleue pourrait
peut-être chez ces les désormais
célèbres costard cravate